- You know, for the
past couple of nights,
here on the program,
we've been dealing
with the fallout
from the Grand jury
decision in Missouri
failing to indict the
officer responsible
for the shooting death
of Michael Brown.
We did our best, here,
to process those events,
even enjoyed,
actually, a bit of fun
at the expense of
the St. Luis Rams
and St. Louis Police
Association Twitter war.
And I know doing those
bits helps no one,
other than, maybe, us here
at the show, individually,
as a creative
outlet, a catharsis,
a way of processing emotion
that might otherwise
be undigested.
By the way, that process
brought to you by:
Arby's.
(audience laughing)
Arby's: You think pain and
grief are hard to digest.
(audience laughing)
But, anyway,
at least that process has begun.
And we were glad to be able to
move forward, ever so slowly,
hoping that we
might, as a country,
have a respite from these
types of injustices,
and we did have a
respite for, maybe,
oh, (bleep), what time is it?
- No indictment in the
death of Eric Garner,
a Grand Jury in New York City
has decided not to charge
a white New York City
police officer in the death
of an unarmed
African American man.
- I just, I don't know.
I honestly don't
know what to say.
If comedy is tragedy plus
time, I need more (bleep) time,
but I would really settle
for less (bleep) tragedy,
to be honest with you.
You know, I think what
is so utterly depressing
is that none of the
ambiguities that existed
in the Ferguson case exist
in the Staten Island case,
and yet the outcome
is exactly the same.
No crime, no trial,
all harm, no foul.
In Ferguson, at least you had
conflicting witness testimony,
you had conflicting forensics,
you had the specter, at
least, of police self-defense.
But here, there is none of that.
The coroner called
it a homicide.
The guy's not acting
threatening, and we know that,
not through witness testimony,
unreliable biased standards,
but because we are
(bleep) watching it.
Someone taped it.
A couple of days ago, the White
House proposed more cameras
on cop vests as a solution
to this type of violence.
I assume that the solution
they're proposing,
if implemented,
would look something like
the Eric Garner case.
I mean, maybe, to look
at the bright side,
we're about to save ourselves
a (bleep) load of money
on cop camera vests.
But, damn.
We are definitely not living
in a post-racial society,
and I can imagine there are
a lot of people out there
wondering how much of a
society we're living in at all.
And, that's our show.
So, cha-cha-cha.
(audience laughing)
(yells)
I don't know what to say,
it just happened so I
have not had a chance
to really digest it.
I'm gonna need a segue,
I'm gonna need a little
piece of video footage
to change the mood here.
(audience laughing)
okay, it's nice, I like it.
Although, in my
current frame of mind,
I can't help but wonder,
"Oh, of course the white
cat's getting a massage.
(audience laughing)
(sighs)
(screams)
(bleep)
(audience laughing)